and you're live chairman
good evening and welcome to this
district's planet meeting um today
wednesday the 19th of january
my name is mark hurd chairman of this
committee
members the setup
for the meeting has been designed to
mitigate for covid therefore can i ask
all present to work to the protocols
agreed at council on the 2nd of
september 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety
i would remind members that one of those
protocols was
that a lateral flow test should be taken
before you attend this meeting
and
i'm sure that you have all taken those
that lateral flow test uh but you have
not necessarily notified that that has
been done
okay
so could i just remind you that you need
to
confirm that by email which is on the
message
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak and i will invite you
at the appropriate time
we are live stream sound recording this
meeting and this is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
uh please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
and keep your contributions clear and
concise
so i draw your attention to the notices
on the agenda papers regarding the
different levels within the chamber and
advise that the fire exit is the door
behind this top table
all members need to confine their
participation to matters relevant to any
agenda item any declaration of interest
should be limited to the declaration
itself it is inappropriate to use public
meetings to make allegations against
employees or other members an official
complaint procedure exists to raise such
allegations and these procedures should
be used and the monitoring officer
should be contacted for further advice
any member that does not comply with
these requirements will be in breach of
my ruling i will warn them to desist and
if they persist i will either adjourn
the meeting or propose that the agenda
item is dealt with without access to the
public under the local government act
1972 scheduled 12a paragraphs one and
two
and that such action satisfies the
public interest test
if we go into private session the live
link will be cut and that member will
have denied the public having access to
the debate
and voting on that item
uh the next agenda item is apologies
miss bird do we have uh well i know we
have a number of apologies please
good evening chairman good evening
members apologies have been received
from council mrs channel councillor
juric councillor durham councillor
edwards councillor helm councillor
huberner council shaughnessy councillor
siddall and councillor stilts
thank you very much we now move on to
declarations of interest
members are reminded that they are
required to declare any disclosable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
which they know they might have in items
of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of a code of conduct for
members and they are reminded that they
will need to repeat their declarations
at the appropriate point in the meeting
and leave the room if required under the
code of conduct unforeseen interests
must be declared similarly at the
appropriate time
agenda item 3 minutes of the previous
meeting is recommended that the minutes
of the meeting of the district planning
committee held on the 2nd of september
20
declarations
sorry councillor fleming
thank you chair a non-pecuniary as a
member of our six county council who are
consultees thank you thank you very much
councillor morris is not part of this
committee and he doesn't have to make a
declaration i'm not asking to make a
declaration but i am asking that the
minutes show that i'm present in the
meeting as in attendance okay thank you
is that going to be done on the meeting
in a minute sorry
well that has been done yes it has been
facing item 3 is minutes of the previous
meeting it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting of the district
planning committee held on the 2nd of
december 2021
found on pages
uh 3 to 10 are approved as a true and
accurate record they're presented for
accuracy only
i so move do i have a seconder
councillor maze thank you does any
member wish to speak on these minutes or
raise a matter of accuracy
can we agree those by by ascent
thank you very much
agenda item 4 uh is to resolve that
under section 100 a four of the local
government act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting on the
following items of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 5 of part 1 of
schedule 12 i have the act and this
satisfy
this satisfies the public interest
test
do i have a seconder
thank you very much councillor boyce
i've also received apologies from
councillor stamp i had received those
earlier thank you
so we are now in private session
you